[Music]
good nothing nothing
you're the spider-man from YouTube am i
shooting wasn't it what are you doing in
my room Miami and you serve a minute
there's a desk oh yes and no healthy
dose I mean mrs. don't know see me my
super that's a toy experiment or short
adventure basically you can't tell
anybody about this guys boo secret super
why would you kids like something we'll
try and cheer me everything on that you
guys let me do this anymore
okay okay okay Kay I'll level with you I
won't answer you to sequence the
producing was ever happen I can't
believe
hey I go hey where you going what are
you hiding
Peter
I'm just kidding out okay what's up guys
so to become an Avenger are there like
trials or an enmity do me a favor can't
you just be a friendly neighborhood
spider-man just stay close to the ground
you're the spider-man from YouTube can
you summon anomalous players oh yeah no
no I happen to still chemistry the
pseudonym that the rich and the powerful
like start they don't care about
the world's changing voice time we
change too
these weapons a crazy dangerous mission
Peter forget the flying monster game
there are people who handle this sort of
thing you read the weapons Barry was a
230 you missed it
[Music]
what if somebody died I was just trying
to be like you I wanted to get better
I'm gonna need the street back nothing
went out they shoot if you're nothing
without this shoot then you shouldn't
have it I screwed up you need to stop
carrying the weight of the world on your
shoulders I want you to understand I'll
do anything to protect my family
I know you know what I'm talking about
I don't know I would kill you and
everybody in your love
a guy is still out there I've just got
to do this on my own
just don't do anything stupid all right
yeah
you